im vergangenen sommer berichtete der
länderspiegel aus dem hessischen hofheim
die häuser hier oben am hasenberg sind
nicht an die kanalisation angeschlossen
die anwohner müssen ihre klärgruben
abpumpen lassen immer schon
doch den auftrag für die arbeiten mit
einem saugte die stadt neu vergeben die
folge die gebühren wurden siebenfach
teurer
bis zu 10.000 euro für einzelne anwohner
wir können nachts wirklich schlecht
schlafen weil das bewegt uns alles weil
es ist wirklich existenzgefährdend nach
unserer sendung kommt bewegung in den
fall
die stadt hofheim schreibt die leerung
der klärgruben noch mal neu aus und
findet tatsächlich einen anbieter der
von nun an wieder zum alten preis
arbeitet die enormen summen die die
anwohner vergangenes jahr zahlen mussten
die sind weg
also es ist vollkommen abstrus wie
dieser betrag in 2009/10 zustande
gekommen ist
die hofheimer klagen jetzt gegen die
unfassbar hohen rechnungen vom
vergangenen jahr parkchaos in koblenz im
vergangenen mai dabei wäre hier
eigentlich platz genug die stadt hatte
diesen schönen neuen parkplatz gebaut
das problem hier darf niemand parken so
schütte jedes mal wenn ich hier
vorbeigehen amiras pause wirklich nur
den kopf der platz ist eigentlich für
ein neues schwimmbad gedacht dass auf
der anderen straßenseite stehen sollte
weil das seit einem jahrzehnt aber nicht
gebaut wird muss der parkplatz
geschlossen bleiben und jetzt wirds ganz
absurd private investoren haben direkt
nebenan ein parkhaus gebaut es wird bald
eröffnet und das obwohl hunderte
städtische stellplätze längst da sind
absurd ist auch das stichwort für diese
bürger im nordrhein westfälischen
velbert
denn hier wurde ein stadtteil komplett
mit schnellem internet ausgebaut aber
diese 16 doppelhaushälften sind leer
ausgegangen die telekom hatte kurz vor
ihrer haustür mit der verkabelung
einfach schluss gemacht
auch zwei jahre nachdem wir erstmals
hier waren herrscht immer noch internet
steinzeit
bei uns ist vom digital pakt nicht viel
angekommen
die stadtwerke velbert versprechen auf
länderspiegel nachfrage dass es für die
anwohner spätestens in fünf jahren
schnelles internet gibt bis dahin heißt
es neidisch in die nachbarschaft gucken
und weiter warten
eigentlich sollte im malchiner ortsteil
schafft so die straßenbeleuchtung in
diesem winter funktionieren so der
bürgermeister im vergangenen februar
unser ziel muss jetzt einfach sein aber
das wird eine vernünftige lösung finden
dass im nächsten winter oder zum herbst
hin dass auch den tadellos funktioniert
doch bis heute ihren die menschen
morgens durch ist stockdunkel ist dorf
seit vier jahren stehen hier hochmoderne
solarlampen aber die schönen neuen
hightech leuchten haben einen ganz
entscheidenden nachteil der solarstrom
reicht einfach nicht aus die lampen
gehen nach wie vor aus nach etwa drei
stunden oder so fallen die ersten aus
bis zum nächsten winter sollen die
solarlampen durch konventionelle
leuchten ersetzt werden
weil aber jede menge fördergelder
geflossen sind darf man die alten dinger
nicht einfach wegwerfen die lampen die
nicht leuchten werden künftig irgendwo
ins stadtgebiet gestellt
und auch im schwarzwald gab es ärger mit
der technik dieser bahnübergang in
kirchzarten wurde komplett umgebaut
doch die neue anlage schlummerte bei
unserem ersten besuch im april schon
monate im dornröschenschlaf jedes mal
wenn sich ein zug näherte mussten zwei
bahnmitarbeiter im handbetrieb die
kreuzung mit rot weißen bändern sichern
ich finde die lachnummer lächerlich ein
dreiviertel jahr später ist die schranke
jetzt endlich im einsatz der hochmoderne
bahnübergang mit radar scanner
funktioniert aber so ganz traut man der
sache wohl nicht immer noch habt ihr ein
sicherheitsmann er guckt bei jedem namen
den zug ob der übergang denn auch
tatsächlich frei ist hightech bei der
bahn im jahr 2020